[Music]
election night [__] 1973 the
[__] cheetah you understand me I
don't give a [__] by the way by the way
if you're leaving the country
cuz Trump wins I got a travel agency in
Cuba
you [__] mutts who gives a [__] or
wins you still gotta get up in the
morning and make it happen
who gives a [__] who gives a [__] get
your [__] together you're gonna hang out
with these [__] Gentiles it don't
know dick about dick you understand me
smoke weed be happy here we go
[Music]
you have to listen to this [__] all day
but who gives a [__] here we go
you better start eating him right now
I'm telling you if you're under 18 hang
up now cuz we're going deep tonight
Lake your mother's [__] captain I
don't give a [__] about your father's on
Friday we'll go in deep if Trump wins
I'm leaving okay oh yeah I'm leaving I'm
packing my bag you [__]
greatest country in the world and you're
worried about this [__] if you're gonna
leave this you left ten [__] years
ago when I had a bomb on you jumping up
and down we love black people now where
ya [__] it stars local joint
[Music]
you play this back [__] we're gonna
put this welcome back tonight in Polish
[Music]
good I guess the Dalek time oh [__]
and one for drunk
[Music]
if you're gonna get down let's get down
all right you want to get down let's get
down [__] come on come on oh you
[__] I'll take his on a house
[__] eggs all out by now throw it away
[Music]
the election who gives a [__] you gotta
get up and steal with three hands if
they're gonna steal you gotta steal
please no stupid all your [__] life
look at me I got a watch after 65 years
that's great
when you're 65 you gotta watch into
Social Security [__] sorry and there
you are with glasses walking around like
the Living Dead you dumb [__]
you gotta get up in the morning steel
gotta go out there and claw and bite
these [__] Gentiles
you'll be worried about who's president
what the [__] is wrong with you what the
[__] is happens on his [__] country
strap on your [__] ball you [__]
morons the [__] is wrong with you two
about it
[Laughter]
[Music]
either a logical fear you beat with just
to [__] and set the metal your [__]
video games is [__] you don't know what
it's like to be hungry on the dirt
former rocket ship and jerk it off into
your [__] hands and let me freeze
never let [__] [__] freeze in your hand
it's not a pretty picture
[Music]
you want dubonnet's I got bonnets
[__] fondants let's do [__]
pockets all right
I wanna hear your [__] stories you
gotta get up early tomorrow to do the
beret don't give a [__] about here we go
[Music]
little [__] Spanish can I run it with
some white kids we lost all mine all
that you think that's the name of this
movie a guy that all in this club went
on to own studio they own the strip club
first the [__] after cheetah
that's where the Jews went when they
wanted us to have a meet with some black
girls some ladders they don't want
nobody to see in the heart of New York
City the hot in New York sleep we put on
YouTube for my brother for these season
whoops play this song on fennel
he's all Jews we bother nobody okay I
don't have election results I don't give
a [__] cuz it don't make a difference
they want to legalize weed you're gonna
do this new ones with weight thing I'm
not gonna smoke weed I'm leaving at 10
grams of weed because and you [__]
[__] oh well Joey you gotta get pen
ten milligrams of edibles do you think
are you [__] [__] or what you
think that applies to Lisa Adam the
master [__] listen to me I was the
master
I was already
[Music]
they'll learn something here finally off
diet right there the first one look at
this [__] look at New York in the
[__] 70 oh [__] you bad [__]
you're still here
that's why I love you how to clean the
pipe out and get it all ready for this
[__] look at all these Porto Ricans on
one stage you got Bordeaux Ricans you
got Cubans you got Jews you got a
tremendous [__] mixed dog she'll feel
his shadow singing he's in the [__]
cell your show the guy with the shirt
Johnny Pacheco is Miss Ellie a show
what's up Lee wait give me the dirty
looks you know you didn't even eat the
mushrooms yet we're going deep tonight
we got the acid we went beat the other
night [__] if you didn't watch it
you [__] up my nose is getting big I
don't know why I used to be a handsome
[__] my hair sticking out what
do you do gives up I'm at the point my
life I got one foot in the grave one up
an ad up for you I feel great
everything's beautiful
we'll find the all-stars on TV there
[Music]
when Hector Lavoe is a background you
got a [__] band look at that Larry
Harlow did you play the piano
look at them look at these dirty [__]
Ricans look at them look at this Jewish
kid right there
look at this Porto Rican reggaeton guys
dancing on stage or rhythm no background
dances this is the way to do it no you
should have gone with the red jacket on
he had a show on that sinful he said
that was the creator of this whole thing
he had a radio show on he played and he
speaks Spanish
Larry Harlow spoke Spanish Larry Harlow
are you [__] kidding me look at this
[__] I was a little kid I saw the movie
I lost my mind I complained and my
Santeria God mother took me to Larry
hollows house and he signed the poster
for me and [__] this haffley's dudes are
into Santeria
so that's oh my god mother had contact
with these [__] you learn
something new every day [__] up is you
said what bong hit what the [__] you
know you don't gotta ask me boys
hate only you sitting over there like
somebody stole your puppy ahead what
happened
let's get over it was together we still
got more stars to eat we got tons of
left I got more stars in the [__]
universe understand me more stars than
the [__] universe got Nick the Toro
in the house [__] ticket dealing with
your joy bananas now you say much cuz
I'm [__] up sometimes when you're
[__] up you don't say nothing you mind
your own business alright
what's the election results then let's
talk to some people here and I taught
you some people are you people are
crying and [__]
[Music]
oh [__] look at least Sonya please spit
not as long again put some nice green
weed Neffe because we likes to grease
you know like the black [__] but down to
the last the [__] it was felt what do
you want me to tell you people you think
I buy weed and put in a museum come over
and look at my weed look at this but I
got [__] that
this [__] goes right to the head
you understand me right to that [__]
look at that weeds and showing your
friend
[Music]
oh jesus [__] baby training training
training dedication you go to the army
you talking you want a small fire here
we go
[Music]
you played [__] that will leave
it shrubs driving a plane
[Music]
Chuchu and what's this more stars people
we don't [__] around it is the church it
what's happened now okay you wanna [__]
around with these imitations go hang on
it's like eating [__] meth listen if
you ain't eatin Hellmann's mayonnaise
you ain't [__] but from time to time I'm
gonna get crack because that's the label
out of it but if you ain't eatin
Hellmann's you can suck my [__]
ballsack okay I don't even know why but
mayonnaise oh I like mayonnaise Leah
race oh [__] put this on for my boy
right here here you go [__] one
more for you people I'm gonna leave this
one for the mouse
it's a sad [__] I am I always
leave something for the [__] Mouse
okay we're gonna start the podcast about
ten minutes and that's it where they
gonna leave you to calm /c / Joey Diaz
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz alright
and you know I love you [__]
what a lose what do you really really at
this age if we kick a hookers gonna do
the market she's gonna suck dick and
Listerine
like every other day of the week no
matter who's president used to neither
what their and mug [__] all
right
and we'll leave it with destiny I'll see
you saturday listen the [__] place is
sold that way you want me to tell you
the Wooper Wooper stun Friday Saturday
night Lisa I asked the MC Foxwoods with
a tuxedo on but you hadn't everything in
this thing and then on the 18th I'm not
at Houston for the coming taking
festival one night one [__] show
dirty fine I'll bash you watched on
Barry Joe Diaz some improv some [__]
BAM
I love you [__] I see you
tomorrow morning to discuss what
happened tonight to wipe the tears off
your face either way
whoever wins stay black